miles de birmanos continúan desafiando a
la cúpula del ejército que rigen el país
desde el primero de febrero su objetivo
es que los militares devuelvan el poder
que se tomaron tras un golpe de estado
no quiero que nuestro país sea gobernado
por los militares porque tendríamos
miedo de salir y protestar contra ellos
bajo este régimen pero estamos
protestando a pesar de tener miedo town
y vergara bajo las protestas se han
recrudecido en los últimos días en total
han fallecido cuatro personas algo que
ha hecho que el g7 se una a la oleada de
condenas al régimen militar durante este
martes se celebró un entierro
multitudinario en la ciudad de mandalay
de donde era una de las víctimas
asesinadas por un disparo este fin de
semana
[Música]
me siento muy triste por perderlo
perdimos al refugio de nuestra familia y
necesito seguir adelante con el resto de
la familia
aunque el ejército niega la represión
cada día se restringen más derechos y en
las últimas horas se prohibió el uso de
la palabra golpe en los medios la
cuestión birmana alarma a la región y
diversas ongs intentaron frenar una
deportación masiva de más de 1000
birmanos desde malasia una corte
prohibió la repatriación alegando que
entre los afectados hay refugiados y
perseguidos políticos pero a pesar de
todo el gobierno la efectuó